ARE HERE AND HERE ON TIME WE'RE
GOING -- TO PROBABLY WAIT FOR
ANOTHER THREE MINUTES -- TO GIVE
A FEW MORE MEMBERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THEIR WAY
HERE.
AND THERE WILL BE AGAIN
[inaudible]
THANK
YEAH [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
OKAY
inaudible]
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
SURE.
GOOD ACTORS WORK.
WITHOUT [inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGAN AND I AM A RECOGNIZE THAT
WE DO HAVE MEMBERS WHO ARE
PROBABLY HAVE OTHER EVENTS THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE THEIR WAY
FROM.
WE DID SAY AND WE DO START AT
ONE THIRTY SO MISTER JOHNSON WE
WILL WELCOME YOU TO COME FORWARD
WITH YOUR A TEAM.
OF THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OF THAT THE UTILITY AND
ENERGY -- COMMITTEE -- IS
HOLDING TODAY -- TO GET OF
MISTER JOHNSON.
WHO IS THE NEW CEO OF?
RPG.
ON OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- TO GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO ASK QUESTIONS.
OF YOU FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE AN OPENING STATEMENT -- AND
THEN WE WILL AT THE VERY END
AFTER MEMBERS ABOUT AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO HAVE A DIALOGUE WITH YOU --
THEN WE WILL OPEN IT UP FOR ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
OR THE PUBLIC WHO'S HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE. TO TO ADDRESS US --
I'M GONNA JUST MAKE A QUICK
OPENING STATEMENT AND THEN I'LL
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO YOU --
AND AGAIN WE THANK YOU FOR FOR
BEING HERE -- BUT I ALSO WANT --
TO AT THE ONSET FIRST RECOGNIZE
OF THE P. JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY
WHICH IS OF PARAMOUNT CONCERN.
TO ALL OF US BUT IS NOT SUBJECT
OF TODAY'S HEARING -- DUE TO THE
COMPLEXITY OF LEGAL
CONFIDENTIALITY.
OF THE BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING IS
NOT ADVISABLE TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND THIS FORUM AT THIS
TIME.
HOWEVER I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
OUR TREMENDOUS CONCERNS WITH
ADVERSE IMPACTS OF THE
BANKRUPTCY ON THE STATE.
ON OUR RATE PAYERS AND
PARTICULARLY ON FIRE VICTIMS WHO
NEED RESOLUTION RESOLUTION.
OF THEIR CLAIMS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
WE ARE MONITORING THE
PROCEEDINGS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO FACILITATE
MOVING FORWARD.
AND ARE MOVING THE UTILITY OUT
OF BANKRUPTCY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
OF MISTER JOHNSON I'M ANXIOUS TO
HEAR FROM YOU TODAY AND CURIOUS
AS TO WHAT YOU WERE THINKING
WHEN YOU TOOK THIS ASSIGNMENT --
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WE ALL NEED
TO HEAR YOUR VISION OF THE
UTILITY.
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE SAFE?
SAFETY ON OUR GRID AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE AND A CLIMATE WITH
GROWING THREATS.
HOW YOU CONSTRUCT IN P. GENIES
SAFETY CULTURE AND OPERATIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS?
AND HOW YOU'RE GOING TO LEAD THE
UTILITIES TRANSITION ZERO CARBON.
RESOURCES.
YOU HAVE NO DOUBT HEARD MISTER
JOHNSON THAT MANY OF US ARE A
BIT CONCERNED.
ABOUT WHETHER YOU ARE THE RIGHT
FIT FOR THIS UTILITY AT THIS
TIME -- YOU HAVE UTILITY THAT IS
UNDER THE CONTROL OF TO FEDERAL
COURTS.
OF WITH A FEW EXCEPTIONS YOU
HAVE A COMPLETELY NEW BOARD.
AND ONE I MIGHT ADD THE DOES NOT
APPEAR TO HELP THE LONG TERM
INTERESTS.
OF THE STATE IN THEIR FIELD OF
VISION.
ALTHOUGH YOU HAVE A GREAT DEAL
OF EXPERIENCE IN THE TRADITIONAL
VERTICAL CONTROL UTILITY WORLD.
YOU MUST HAVE QUICKLY GRASS BY
NOW THAT ARE UTILITIES ARE VERY
DIFFERENT IN STRUCTURE ND
MISSION.
SO IT'S A BIT HARD FOR SOME OF
US TO SEE THAT YOU'RE THE RIGHT
PERSON ALTHOUGH.
WE ARE CERTAINLY LOOKING FORWARD
TO YOU APPROVING THIS WRONG AT
THIS TIME THE MANAGERS THROUGH
THE STORM AND KEEP US ON TRACK
TO MEET OUR GOALS.
BUT YOU WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONVINCE US OTHERWISE.
HAS CO CO HOW DO YOU LEAD.
CHOOSE ME SORRY DIDN'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT YOU BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY SOMETHING IT'S AN OPENING
STATEMENT.
THAT'S THAT'S FINE -- CAN YOU
LEAD AT THIS TIME.
IDEALLY THE BOARD.
OR DOES THE LORD LEAD YOU --
LIKE WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
YOUR THOUGHTS AND ESTABLISHING A
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOU.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN YOUR TENURE -- I'D
LIKE TO I WAS AT THIS POINT
GOING TO TURN TO YOU -- TO HAVE
YOUR OPENING STATEMENTS AT WHICH
TIME I WILL TURN BACK TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND ALL FIRST
AT THAT TIME TURN TO MISTER
QUIRK DOCTOR QUIRK HAD TO GIVE
HIM AN OPPORTUNITY AND OTHERS.
TO HAVE AN OPENING STATEMENT AS
WELL.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
WITH YOU TODAY.
AS YOU CAN PROBABLY ALREADY TELL
I'M NOT A NATIVE.
THE I SPENT THE LAST SIX YEARS
IN KNOXVILLE TENNESSEE RUNNING
THE TENNESSEE VALLEY AUTHORITY.
WHICH WAS THE FIRST ACT --
PRESENT ROOSEVELT AND THE NEW
DEAL IN THE LAST REMAINING PART
OF THE NEW DEAL.
BEFORE THAT I SPENT NEARLY FOUR
DECADES IN NORTH CAROLINA THE
LAST FIVE OR SIX AS THE CEO OF
THE UTILITY.
AND I OWE YOU LIKE PGA ANY CALL
PROGRESS ENERGY.
I AM A SOUTHERNER AND SO IF I'M
UNABLE TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
WITHOUT AN OCCASIONAL Y'ALL.
HELLO APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE.
SOME APPROACHING TWO WEEKS OF
SERVICE AT P. GINNY I NOW HAVE
ENCYCLOPEDIC KNOWLEDGE OF ALMOST
EVERYTHING THE BUT I DO HAVE
ABOUT ALMOST FORTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN AROUND THE UTILITY
BUSINESS.
AS A UTILITY LAWYER AND
EXECUTIVE.
AS FOR MY CURRENT BOTH PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE PARTS OF THE UTILITY
INDUSTRY HAS DRAWN THE TV A
PARTICULARLY IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR.
BY THE SERVICE OPPORTUNITY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP MAKE
PEOPLE'S LIVES EVERY DAY.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHY I JOIN THE
UTILITY INDUSTRY MANY YEARS AGO
AFTER A CAREER AS A LAWYER.
UTILITY COMPANIES ARE IN THE
BUSINESS OF MAKING PEOPLE'S
LIVES BETTER.
THAT'S THE REASON WE EXIST
THAT'S OUR PURPOSE. TO PROVIDE
THAT SERVICE THAT PEOPLE REALLY
CAN'T DO WITHOUT -- AND THIS IS
MY SECOND WEEK IN THIS CHAIR YOU
MENTIONED THIS SINCE I STARTED
ACTUALLY SINCE I FIRST TALKED
WITH THE COMPANY ABOUT DOING
THIS THE MOST COMMON QUESTION
I'VE GOT NEWS.
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS IT COMES
IN VARIOUS FORMS ARE YOU NUTS
WHAT DO YOU THINK IN -- BUT IT'S
BEEN THE MOST COMMON QUESTION.
WHY WOULD ANYONE WANT TO LEAD A
BANKRUPT CONVICTED?
AND UNPOPULAR PJ.
WHEN I COULD HAVE EASILY RETIRED
I RETIRED TWICE ACTUALLY OF A
MEDICARE CARD IN MY WALLET --
COULD RETIRED IN COMFORT I DON'T
THINK I HAVE ANYTHING LEFT TO
PROVE THEM SORTED OUT HERE TO
BURNISH BY BUSINESS RESUME.
SO WHY TAKE ON ALL THIS TROUBLE.
NEVER BEEN A BANKRUPTCY NEVER
BEEN.
ON PAROLE NEVER BEEN CONVICTED
OF A MISDEMEANOR MY LAST TRAFFIC
CITATION WAS NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX SO.
WHY DO THIS THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION UP FOR A LOT ABOUT
[inaudible]
AND THE ANSWER THAT IN SEEK THIS
JOB.
AND I'M NOT SHARP TOOK WE WANT
THIS JOB.
BUT THIS JOB HAS CALLED ME --
THEN REASON IS I CARE ABOUT
THESE THINGS.
I CARE ABOUT THE INDUSTRY I CARE
ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT HAS ON THE
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY OF THE
NATION.
AT WHAT IT DOES FOR PEOPLE I
CARE ABOUT P. JEANNIE AND I'LL
TELL YOU.
THE ENTIRE INDUSTRY CARES ABOUT
PGA ANY OF WHAT HAS GONE ON
HERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF CONCERN
ABOUT THIS.
AN ESSENTIAL ROLE THAT UTILITIES
PLAN CALIFORNIA CARE ABOUT
CUSTOMERS.
I CARE ABOUT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN INJURED OR HAD LOST IN
THESE TERRIBLE EVENTS
[inaudible]
ELLEN.
I REALLY CARE ABOUT DOING
EVERYTHING I CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN AND WE
CAN GET TO THAT IN A MOMENT.
ALSO CARE PERSONALLY
PROFESSIONALLY ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS DEALING
WITH.
THAT I CARE ABOUT IS GETTING THE
RIGHT ANSWERS TO THOSE QUESTIONS
SO.
I THINK GIVEN MY BACKGROUND MY
EXPERIENCE AND THE FACT THAT I
OWE NOTHING TO ANYBODY OTHER
THAN TO DO THE RIGHT THING EVERY
DAY -- I'M I CAN HELP WITH THESE
CHALLENGES.
HAVE PARTICULARLY THE IMMEDIATE
CHALLENGES BEFORE PGN.
THAT'S WHY I CAME TO P. JEANNIE
THAT'S WHY I CAME TO SEE YOU
TODAY.
BECAUSE I CARE ABOUT THESE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO HELP FIX.
IT'S REALLY QUITE THAT SIMPLE.
IT MIGHT HELPFUL FOR SPOKE INTO
THE MIKE.
SO AND APART FROM WHO I AM AND
ABOUT ME THE OTHER BIG QUESTION
IS.
WORRIED ABOUT WILD FIRE SAFETY.
I WANT TO ENSURE THAT IN TWO
PARTS FIRST WHAT P. GINNY IS
DOING AND THEN WHAT I'M DOING AS
ITS CEO.
SO VICE TO PROGRAM THE VISUAL A
VISUALLY INSPECT EVERY INCH OF
OUR EQUIPMENT IN THE HIGH FIRE
THREAT DISTRICTS.
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF STRUCTURES POLLS.
ALL KINDS OF EQUIPMENT.
BANNING LITERALLY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MILES.
AND I'VE BEEN PROVIDING UPDATES
ON THIS TO THE CPU SAID OTHERS
WE'VE INTENSIFIED OUR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT KNOWS AREAS.
INCREASING THE CLEARANCES AROUND
EQUIPMENT TARGETING PARTICULAR
TREE SPECIES ARE MOST
PROBLEMATIC AND FIRE SEASON.
WE'VE EXPANDED PROCEDURES FOR
TURNING UP THE POWER FOR SAFETY
DURING WILDFIRE THREATS.
AND INCREASING OUR CUSTOMER
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES AND
EDUCATION ACTIVITIES SO THEY
WILL KNOW WHAT TO DO AND HOW TO
REMAIN SAFE IN THOSE INSTANCES.
HELLO TERRY THESE ARE ALL
IMPORTANT THINGS IS A VITALLY
IMPORTANT.
AND I BELIEVE SUBMIT SAYING IT'S
COMING MAYBE NEXT WEEK THE HEAD
OF OUR COMMUNITY WHILE FIRE
SAFETY PROGRAM WHO IS REALLY THE
BRAINS BEHIND THIS OPERATION AND
HE WILL HAVE MUCH MORE DETAIL.
SO THESE ARE IMPORTANT BUT I DO
KNOW THIS THERE'S NOTHING THAT'S
TO ME OR I OR ANYBODY AT P.
GINNY CAN SAY THAT'S GONNA
MATTER ONE BIT.
ANOTHER WE CAN SAY THAT MATTERS
ONE BIT.
UNLESS WE LIVE UP TO OUR WORDS
AND OUR COMMITMENTS.
CANNOT RESTORE TRUST.
WITHOUT RESULTS YOU CAN'T
RESTORE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
RHETORIC.
SO I DO KNOW THIS AFTER FORTY
YEARS OF DOING THIS.
WE CAN ONLY DO THAT WITH RESULTS
WITH OUR PERFORMANCE AND THOSE
RESULTS HAVE TO BE BASED ON
FOCUSING ON THE RIGHT THINGS AND
CLEAR ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
RESULTS.
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK I CAN
HELP OF MY TIME THE TVA WE WERE
CHIEF THE BEST SAFETY RECORD IN
THE ENTIRE EIGHTY FIVE YEAR
HISTORY OF THAT ENTITY.
EVERY YEAR I WAS THERE WE WERE A
TOP DECILE PERFORMING INDUSTRY
AND SAFETY.
ON THE SAFETY FRONT WE WILL BE
BOLSTERED BY CHRIS HARD TO
FORMER NTSB CHAIRMAN WHO IS.
GOING TO BE A SPECIAL
INDEPENDENT SAFETY ADVISER
REPORTING TO ME.
AND SO I WILL TELL YOU WE WILL
BE LASER FOCUSED ON SAFETY.
BUT I WON'T EXPECT YOU TO
BELIEVE THAT UNTIL YOU SEE THE
RESULTS.
YOU KNOW THE OUTCOME FOR THE
PEOPLE.
THE CITIZENS THE CUSTOMERS HAVE
TO BE BETTER.
MISS PART OF THE REASON I HEAR
THAT WHAT THE OUTCOMES OF NOT
BEEN GOOD AND I THINK THE
OUTCOMES HAVE TO START BY
CHANGING THE FOCUS ON SAFETY.
AND NOT JUST FOR SAFETY SAKE
WHICH IS IMPORTANT BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT ALMOST ANY INDUSTRY THE
SAFEST ENTITIES ARE ALSO THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL.
YOU CAN DRAW A DIRECT COMPARISON
TO SUCCESSFUL COMPANIES AND
THEIR SAFETY RECORDS.
AND SAFETY CULTURE.
SIMPLY CAN'T BE IMPOSED FROM THE
TOP DOWN I'M NOT GONNA CHANGE
ANYTHING BY SAYING TOMORROW.
OKAY WE'RE ALL GOING TO BE SAFE.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO IS MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY IS A LINE?
ON WHAT'S IMPORTANT THE RIGHT
BEHAVIORS ARE RIGHT STANDARDS
AND FOLLOWING THAT SAFETY
CULTURES ABOUT ALIGNMENT AT THE
PERSONAL AND ORGANIZATIONAL
LEVEL. TO A SET OF BEHAVIORS AND
BELIEFS AND THEN A COMMITMENT TO
YOUR FELLOW WORKER. TO THE
COMMUNITY TO THE CUSTOMER.
MY CHALLENGES THE LEADER IS
GOING TO BE TO INSTALL AND STILL
THESE TRAITS.
AND THIS COMMITMENT.
THERE'S A PROBLEM WE NEED TO
SOLVE [inaudible]
AND I'M.
PERSONALLY AWARE OF THE IMPACT
OF THESE THINGS IN MY SHORT TIME
HERE I'VE BEEN TO PARADISE TO
SANTA ROSA AND SAN BRUNO.
AND I DID NONE OF THAT IS A
PUBLICITY STUNT I WILL TELL YOU
THAT I DON'T DO PUBLICITY STUNTS.
BUT I WANT TO GO SEE YOU KNOW
YOU CAN READ ABOUT IT YOU CAN
HEAR ABOUT IT TELL YOU THOUGH
SHE YOU REALLY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THIS I MET WITH.
VICTIMS WITH PEOPLE HAVE LOST
FAMILY MEMBERS HOMES ELECTED
OFFICIALS -- I WILL TELL YOU A
SOMBER.
SOBERING HEART WRENCHING
EXPERIENCE FOR ME [inaudible]
OF WHICH JUST FURTHER MY RESOLVE
THE SAY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN.
TO NOT LET THAT HAPPEN AGAIN THE
OTHER THING WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON
IS THE CLEAN ENERGY GOALS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. ONE OF THE
REASONS I JOIN THE INDUSTRY IN
PARTICULAR MY TIME A TV A WAS TO
HELP CONSERVE OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES -- I BELIEVE IN
CLIMATE CHANGE AND I'M ON THE
RECORD SINCE THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS.
I'VE READ SOME STORIES ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED THE TVA THAT ARE
NOT QUITE FACTUALLY ACCURATE AND
I'LL BE GLAD TO CLARIFY THAT
RECORD -- RISE IT PROGRESS WE
WERE THE FIRST COMPANY IN SOUTH
BEACH TO START CLOSING COAL
PLANTS.
MY TIME A TV A WE WENT FROM 60%
OF OUR ENERGY FOR FROM COLD A
17% -- TV A IN A COUPLE OF YEARS
WILL OF REDUCED ITS CARBON
FOOTPRINT BY 70%.
WHICH IS REMARKABLE THING GIVEN
WHERE THEY STARTED.
AND I'M PARTICULARLY INTERESTED
IN HELPING BUILD A CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT TO ME AS
ANY OTHER REASON I CAME HERE.
FOR SO THAT'S ME THAT'S WHY I'M
HERE AND I'LL BE GLAD.
TO IN MY LIMITED KNOWLEDGE
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
THANK YOU ARE BEFORE WE IS ME
TURN TO THE MEMBERS LET ME JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT -- BRIAN DOLLY
AND DR JIM WOOD OR A JOINING US
TODAY THEY ALL WERE MEMBERS OF
THE NINE OH ONE COMMISSION LAST
WEEK -- LAST YEAR AND WERE THE
CONFEREES FROM THE ASSEMBLY AND
SO WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THEY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE A
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION AS
WELL SO THEY'LL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS
ALONG WITH.
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OF DOCTOR QUIRK I THINK YOU HAD.
I WANTED TO MAKE A FEW OPENING
THIS IS AN OPENING STATEMENT
WHICH YOU PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
RESPOND -- TO SHOT BY THE WAY
ALL SEVEN MEDICARE CARD OF ALSO
RETIRED TWICE WE HAVE THAT IN
COMMON ALSO MY SON -- WORKS DOWN
SEVERAL LEVELS FROM YOU AND
ENERGY ACQUISITION WHICH RIGHT
NOW IS DE ACQUISITION -- BECAUSE
OF THE LOSS OF THE RETAIL.
I LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS RIGHT NOW
AND THE PLIGHT OF THE RATE
PAYERS DUE TO FAILURE STATE
GOVERNMENT.
HAD WE PREVENTED THE BANKRUPTCY
WE WOULD NO LONGER WE WOULD NOT
HAVE TO PAY YOU INTEREST RATES
FOR BONDS WE WOULD NOT HAVE TO
PAY 11% FOR EQUITY.
AROUND THE RATHER THE RIGHT
NUMBER.
THAT'S WHAT P. JEANNIE AND IS
SUGGESTED ALL RIGHT NUMBERS NINE
OF TANNER TWELVE BUT I DO KNOW
WHY IT'S BECAUSE THE MARKET HAS
LOST FAITH.
NOT ONLY IN P. JEANNIE BUT IN
THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
UP EITHER ABILITY OR WILLINGNESS
TO PREVENT A BANKRUPTCY IS NOT
ONLY P. JEANNIE AT THIS POINT.
IT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
IT'S SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC
WHICH EVERYONE AGREES HAS HAD
THE BEST -- FIRE SAFETY PROGRAM
AND YET THESE TWO ARE BASICALLY
JUST ONE STEP ABOVE JUNK BOND
STATUS -- INTO WHY IT WENT INTO.
P. JEANNIE WENT INTO BANKRUPTCY
NOT BECAUSE AT THE TIME AT LEAST
THEY HAD A HUGE AMOUNT TO PAY
THAT HADN'T BEEN DECIDED YET
WHAT AND IT STILL HASN'T BEEN
DECIDED.
WHAT FIRES WERE CAUSED BY P.
JEANNIE BUT BECAUSE OF THE FEAR
THAT THEY WOULD BE FOUND TO OF
BECAUSE THE FIRES?
AND THE FACT THAT THE STATE.
THROUGH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WAS UNWILLING TO DO
ANYTHING [inaudible]
OF PRESIDENT PEAVEY OF THE C. P.
YOU SEE WHAT WE HAVE A TALKING
BIRD I I REALLY DON'T ARE AYE
INTO.
NINE WE FAILED AND THE IMPACT IS
COMING ON THE RATE PAYERS.
IT'S COMING IN THE TYPES OF THE
BONDS OF AND FURTHER WE WOULDN'T
HAVE TO HAVE WALL STREET TYPES
ON THE BOARD HAD WE STOP THE
BANKRUPTCY [inaudible] THREE
DOLLARS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE PART OF YOUR
COMMITTEE I I MISS THIS
COMMITTEE QUITE QUITE A BIT.
SO -- WE'VE HEARD.
IN THE PAST A LOT ABOUT -- TRUST
ME AND YOU KNOW WE IT'S ON YOUR
SHOULDERS.
TO BUILD THAT TRUST BACK IN.
THE RATE PAYERS AND PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT TO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY.
SOME I THINK AND THE FAILINGS OF
THE COMPANY I THINK MR QUIRK
BRINGS UP THERE'S BEEN SOME
FAILINGS ELSEWHERE SO -- I
REPRESENT A BIG PART OF THE
TERRITORY THAT PGD DELIVERS --
POWER TO MY CUSTOMERS ARE TO MY
CONSTITUENTS -- COUPLE THINGS
NUMBER ONE THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
SHUTTING DOWN POWER WHEN WE HAVE.
EVENTS WORDS HIGH WIND AND MEN
WERE WE HAVE RISK.
AND SO A LOT OF WE NEED SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THAT'S
GONNA WORK THERE'S A LOT OF
FOLKS OUT THERE THAT ARE ARE.
FEARFUL THAT IT DID NEED POWER
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO MINIMIZE
OUR WRISTS BUT WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE I GUESS -- GOING INTO
THE FUTURE AS FAR AS OUT OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE MANY OF
THEM ON LIFE'S THE LIFE SUPPORT
SYSTEM DIALYSIS DOM'S.
MEDICALLY -- HE THOSE SAY WHAT
DOES IT LOOK LIKE I MEAN I I'VE
HEARD SOME COMMERCIALS.
THEY'VE BEEN OUT THERE TRYING TO
START THE PROCESS AS PROCESS OF
EDUCATING THE THERE'S LITERALLY --
YOU KNOW MILLIONS OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE WHO DON'T.
WE NEED SOMEWHERE TO COMMUNICATE
DIRECTLY WITH THEM TO LET THEM
KNOW WHAT THE PROCESS IS GOING
TO BE.
SO I'M NOT EVADING YOUR QUESTION
I'LL GET TO IT IMMEDIATELY BUT I
WANT TO SAY WHEN SUBMIT SAYING
GETS HERE HE CAN GIVE YOU THIS
TO YOU IN GREAT DETAIL SO IF YOU
HAVE TIME WHEN HE COMES. TO BE
INVITED BACK THAT WOULD BE GOOD
BUT THE THIS IS THE IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
FIRST OF ALL WHY SHUT OFF THE
POWER -- AND THIS IS A QUESTION
OF PRIORITIES.
IF YOU CAN'T KEEP IT SAFE FOR
THE CURRENT CONFIGURATION OF THE
SYSTEM HUMAN LIFE HAS TO BE OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
AND SO THAT'S THE THINKING
BEHIND THIS.
WE WERE WELL PREPARED LAST YEAR.
THAT WAS OBVIOUS WERE BETTER
PREPARED THIS YEAR MUCH BETTER
PREPARE.
MUCH BETTER DIAGNOSTIC ABILITY --
AND I CAN'T GIVE YOU THE
PERIODICITY WITH WHICH WE WILL
DO THIS BUT WE HAVE SPENT A
GREAT DEAL OF TIME PREPARING FOR
THIS -- AND WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LOCAL EMS SO THAT
PEOPLE WILL KNOW WHERE TO GO.
WE ARE.
INTENT ON GIVING A LOT OF
ADVANCE NOTICE.
WE LIKE TO GIVE FORTY EIGHT
HOURS IF WE CAN REPEATED AT
TWENTY FOUR AND THEN IMMEDIATELY
BEFORE THE EVENT.
WE ARE WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SAY CAN WE SET UP
A SHELTER IN THIS GYMNASIUM WERE
IDENTIFYING.
MEDICAL NEED PATIENCE SO I THINK
WE'RE DOING ALL THE RIGHT THINGS
HERE.
THEY'RE STILL A LITTLE
COORDINATION TO GO.
BUT I THINK WE WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE.
AND I THINK WE'RE DOING ALL THE
RIGHT THINGS TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
READY.
SO LAST YEAR THEY ACTUALLY SHUT
THE POWER OFF.
BEFORE WE HAD -- THE EVENTS AND
I KNOW.
DOCTOR WOODS IN MY DISTRICT BUT
WAS FORTY HE'S BEFORE CAME BACK
ON SO NOBODY WAS EXPECTING WITH
THE WIND OF IT WAS OVER.
HE WAS GONE AND WAS FOUR DAYS
LATER THAT FARMERS WERE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEY'RE GOING.
TO WHAT OTHER FIELDS I MEAN I
WAS GETTING CALLS LIKE CRAZY.
OF PEOPLE LIKE WHEN IS IT
ACTUALLY COME BACK ON SO I GUESS
FOR ME I WANT I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO BE SAFE.
AND I WANT TO AVOID THOSE RISKY
TIMES BUT THOSE TIMES ARE SHORT
WINDOWS THAT WE NEED TO ACTUALLY
SHUT THE POWER DOWN.
AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE GONNA SS BECAUSE
WHAT I I CALL ACTUALLY CALLED.
P. JEANNIE MYSELF AND SAID ONE
OF MY GONNA GET POWER BACK ON MY
DISTRICT.
AND HE SAID AS SOON AS WE SURVEY
EVERY SINGLE LINE AS YOU JUST
STATED IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
THERE'S TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
MILES OF LINES OUT THERE.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT JUST AREAS THAT ARE SHUT
DOWN BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF A SYSTEM AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE FOUR DAYS EVERY TIME
THE AS THE NEXT OF IT PRETTY
COULD BE EIGHT DAYS WITHOUT
POWER.
AND THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE EITHER
IS WE HAVE TO HAVE A SYSTEM IN
PLACE THAT ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE.
TO SHUT THE POWER OFF DURING
THOSE.
EVENTS WHERE WE HAVE WE KNOW
THERE'S A HIGH RISK AND THEN BE
ABLE TO GET IT BACK ON IN A
FASHION WHERE PEOPLE ARE TOTALLY
IMPACTED AS WELL THE SAME TIME
[inaudible]
SO.
WHEN I HEARD THAT THE
RESTORATION TIME WAS TWO AND A
HALF TO FOUR DAYS -- I HAVE TO
SAY MY I WAS MY JOB DROPPED --
BUT AND THIS IS NOT AN EXCUSE
BUT THIS IS A FACT THE
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM WAS BUILT.
TO REMAIN IN SERVICE.
RIGHT THE FOCUS IS ALWAYS BAD
AND HOW DO YOU KEEP IT WORKING
NINETY NINE POINT 999% OF THE
TIME.
AND TURNING IT OFF IS NOT
SOMETHING WE HAVE HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH YOU KNOW WE STARTED BACK IN
WHEN THERE'S A FAILURE BUT SO
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS AND I
WILL SAY THE THE PHYSICS.
I DON'T GET TOO FAR TO PHYSICS
BUT THE PHYSICS OF RE ENERGIZING
A TRANSMISSION SYSTEM ARE NOT A
SIMPLE DISTRICTS WHICH THERE ARE
SOME COMPLEXITY TO THIS.
NONE OF THAT GOES TO THE POINT
OF FOUR DAYS IS RIDICULOUS HI
KATHY.
YEAH I AGREE WITH THAT I THINK
WE'RE BETTER SHAPE.
OVER TIME THERE ARE AS A QUICK
MEANT YOU CAN INSTALL ON THE
LINE THAT'S IN THE PLAN THAT
MAKES THIS A LOT EASIER.
I WON'T BORE YOU WITH THOSE
DETAILS BUT WE WILL DO BETTER
THIS YEAR.
I AND I THINK IN I'M GONNA TURN
DR -- TO YOU AS WELL BUT I
WANTED TO JUST ALSO LET YOU KNOW
IN THE COMMITTEE THAT WE WILL BE
HEARING OF ANY HEARING NEXT WEEK.
ON THE WALL FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS AND THEN THE OTHER TWO
UTILITIES WILL BE HERE AS WELL.
TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH INCLUDES --
DINNER DISEASE.
THAT WAS GOOD.
SO WITH SO THE NO WAY BECAUSE
PART MY QUESTION WAS GOING TO BE
AROUND THAT VERY ISSUE OF
GETTING IT BACK ON AND JUST --
AND I'M SURE I MEAN AND AND
THANK YOU FOR GOING OUT AND
VISITING SOME OF THE SITES
BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE DEAL WITH.
IN ADDITION TO SAVING HUMAN LIFE
IS ALSO THE LEVEL OF TRAUMA THAT
PEOPLE HAVE LIVED THROUGH.
AND THE LEVEL OF ANXIETY THAT
THEY NOW EXPERIENCE -- CHILDREN
OLDER PEOPLE YOU KNOW I MEAN FOR
A PARTY TO TRY TO DO THEIR
BUSINESS BUT THEN THE REAL THE
REAL FEAR THAT EXIST AND
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DECIMATED.
BY THESE FIRES A WHOLE SUPPORT
SYSTEMS CANNOT YOU KNOW RIPPED
APART.
AND I THINK WE'LL SEE THAT. FOR
YEARS TO COME THE IMPACT ON ON
KIDS -- AS A LIVE THROUGH THIS --
SO I GUESS PARTY YOUR OPENING
STATEMENTS AND AND WELCOME.
WELCOME A IS YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT WAS YOU KNOW YOU NEVER
BEEN BANKRUPTCY YOU KNOW.
SO WHAT PREPARE YOU TO COME TO A
STATE A BIG STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA AND YOU CAN SEE IT'S
RAINING NOW WHICH MEANS TO US.
THAT MEANS WILDFIRE SEASON IS
GOING TO BE.
EVEN EVEN WORSE -- BRINGS YOU TO
STATE I CALIFORNIA WITH OUR HUGE --
ADD GOALS ABOUT RENEWABLES WITH
TO THAT'S A HUGE JOB TO WORK ON
EVERY URBAN TO BANKRUPTCY.
I CUT WHICH YOUR PLANNER OR WHAT
IN YOUR PAST HAVE DO YOU THINK
PREPARES YOU TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS.
AND I GUESS.
NOW WE'VE ALL READ THINGS ABOUT.
ABOUT YOU -- AND HOW LONG YOU
PLAN ON STAYING.
I'LL TAKE THE LAST PART LAST
CALLED ABOUT THE SO I HAVE RUN
BIG SYSTEMS I'M IN THE PJ
SEVENTY THOUSAND SQUARE MILES.
THE TV IS. EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
SQUARE MILES.
OF AND SO BIG SYSTEMS -- THAT'S
NOT A SURPRISE TO ME I AM A
LAWYER I'VE.
ACTUALLY VAN AROUND BANKRUPTCY
AND I'VE ACTUALLY DONE SOME
LEGAL WORK AS A YOUNG LAWYER AND
I HATED IT SO I NEVER DID
ANYMORE -- BUT BUT REALLY
BANKRUPTCY IS A PROCESS IT'S NOT
THAT COMPLICATED UNDERSTAND THIS
IS A THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
COMPLICATED BANKRUPTCY IN
AMERICAN HISTORY THIS -- ONE AND
HERE'S THERE'S A WHOLE.
ROAD SHOW SIDE INDUSTRY THAT
GOES WITH BANKRUPTCY IT'S ALL
THE SAME PEOPLE THEY SHOW UP SO.
BUT I HAVE BEEN AROUND A LOT OF
CATASTROPHE.
I'VE DEALT WITH TORNADOES
HURRICANES MAJOR EVENTS I KNOW A
LOT ABOUT THAT.
THE REGULATORY SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA IS UNLIKE ANY.
ONE ELSE IN THE COUNTRY.
I GREW UP AS A REGULATORY LAWYER.
AND TRIED MANY CASES INCLUDING
CASES HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
REGULATORY SCHEME SO.
YEAH I HAVE A PRETTY BROAD
EXPERIENCE OF REGULATORY LEGAL
OPERATIONAL SAFETY [inaudible]
FINANCIAL -- SO I THINK I COME
ABOUT AS CLOSE AS YOU CAN TO FIT
IN THE BILL ABOUT WHAT'S NEEDED
THAT [inaudible]
EDIT THAT.
YOU THINK ABOUT WHO WOULD COME
AND DO THIS.
MINISTERS OVER A HIGH RISK.
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME PEOPLE. FOR
A FIFTY YEAR OLD RISING STAR
YOU'RE NOT TAKING THIS JOB.
I HAVE NO CAREER RISK.
AT SEVEN AS PART OF IT FOR ME
IT'S A IT REALLY DOES I MEANT
WHEN I SAID THE REASON I CAME IS
I THINK I CAN HELP AND SOMEBODY
HAS TO HELP.
SO I'M WILLING THAT'S PART OF SO
I I I HAD THE TERRIBLE
EXPERIENCE BUT A GROWING
EXPERIENCE OF SERVING ON AND
STOCKTON CITY COUNCIL AND WE
WENT THROUGH BANKRUPTCY.
AND THAT WAS IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE GAINFUL
EXPERIENCE FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED -- BUT BUT WE ARE NOW
STOCKTON AS A CITY IS NOW ON THE
RACE BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
VERY STRATEGICALLY REBUILD FROM
WHERE WE WERE.
AND YOU CAN YOU CAN SEE THE
DECISIONS PEOPLE MADE AND HOW
THEY LEAD TO THE CITY BEING IN A
MUCH STRONGER POSITION NOW.
WHEN YOU WE P. GINNY WHAT WE
LOOK TO TO KNOW THAT YOU HAVE?
LEFT A BETTER THAN YOU FOUND.
GREAT QUESTION.
FIRST OF ALL NO MORE THESE BIG
EVENTS.
THAT'S GOT TO BE THE FIRST THING
AND IF YOU LOOK AT I MEAN.
LOOK AT THE HISTORY OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS OF REPETITION
OF EVENTS.
THIS IS THE THIRD BANKRUPTCY
INVOLVING P. JEANNIE ONE WAS A
SUBSIDIARY BUT THIS IS NUMBER
THREE I THINK THERE'S BEEN SIX
IN THE ENTIRE UTILITY INDUSTRY
OVER TIME SO.
AND THEIR EVENT DRIVEN -- SO
FIRST THING.
WE HAVE TO CONDUCT OUR BUSINESS
IN A WAY THAT PROHIBITS BUT YOU
CAN'T PROHIBIT BUT MINIMIZES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE EVENTS.
AND THAT HAS TO DO WITH SAFETY
CULTURE PAYING ATTENTION TO
DETAIL RISK IDENTIFICATION RISK
MITIGATION.
ASSET PRIORITIZATION
UNDERSTANDING YOUR BUSINESS SO
FIRST THAT'S FIRST.
LET US LEARN HOW TO RUN THE
BUSINESS ABOUT HAVING THESE BIG
RISK.
TO LET THIS SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF LIKE THIS
TOO IF WE'VE LOST A RETAIN OUR
POSITION AS THE LEADER OF THE
CLEAN ENERGY IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT I THINK THE
BANKRUPTCY WILL AFFECT THAT A
LITTLE BIT IN THE SHORT TERM.
AND THREE SO I BELIEVE IN
REDEMPTION.
NOW WHAT SOME REDEMPTION FOR PGA
ANY IN THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
THE CUSTOMERS AND THE PEOPLE IN
THIS BUILDING AND ELSEWHERE
[inaudible]
EARN REDEMPTION.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'D.
I DON'T ACTUALLY BELIEVE IN
LEGACY.
THANK YOU LITTLE HUBRIS INVOLVED
WITH THE BUT I DO BELIEVE IN THE
CONCEPT AS YOU SAID OF LEAVING
IT BETTER THAN IF.
WE COULD DO THAT.
HOW LONG WILL THAT TAKE -- HOW
LONG AM I WILLING TO DO THIS I
GUESS IS A BETTER QUESTION --
YOUNG HEALTHY FIT.
WILLING BUT AS LONG AS IT TAKES
A FAKE.
DO NOT INCOME HERE.
WITH THE IDEA THAT THIS WAS A
SHORT THING [inaudible]
NOW.
BUT WE'LL SEE BUT I'D LIKE TO
FIX IT.
THAT'S IF YOU ACTUALLY TALK TO
PEOPLE IN INDUSTRY ABOUT ME
THERE WAS A YEAH HE'S WITH HIS
THE FIX IT GOT SO.
THERE'S A BIG FIX.
IT IS IN THE WENDY.
IT'S CRAZINESS CHAIR HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MISS JOHNSON THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
MY NAME'S WHEN HE GOT THE I
REPRESENT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE IN EAST LA.
P. GENIE IS IS NOT IN MY AREA
BUT I DID -- RECENTLY GO ON A
VISIT TO PARADISE WITH OTHER
COLLEAGUES.
AND IT'S A QUITE DIFFERENT TO
SEE IT FIRSTHAND THE DEVASTATION
AND THE IMPACT HUMAN LIVES --
THAN TO JUST READ ABOUT IT IN
THE NEWSPAPER OR SEE IT ON
TELEVISION.
AND THE IMPACT THAT THE QUALITY
OF THEIR THAT WE ALL BREATHE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IMPACTS ALL OF US THESE
WILDFIRES IMPACT RESIDENTS IN
EAST LA JUST AS THEY DO
RESIDENTS AND AND PARADISE AND
AND THE AFFECTED AREAS.
I THINK TRUST IS A WORD THAT
OFTEN COMES UP IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE FUTURE P. JEANNIE LOOKS LIKE.
HOW DO WE ESTABLISH TRUST TO YOU
AS A AS A LEADER OF THIS COMPANY
NOW?
HOW DO YOU WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE I'D LOVE TO HEAR
LIKE MAYBE SOME OF YOUR PLANS IN
THE NEXT THREE TO SIX MONTHS?
AS TO THE IMPLEMENTATION SO YOU
WILL TAKE TO CHANGE OR THE
LEADERSHIP THAT YOU WILL HAVE
WITHIN THE COMPANY.
AND HOW YOU PLAN ON LETTING US
KNOW IN THE LEGISLATURE.
ABOUT YOUR PROGRESS OR SO
CHALLENGES THAT YOU MAY BE
FACING -- SO THAT AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE WORK TOWARDS
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA PAIRS.
AND ENSURING THAT THERE IS TRUST
WITHIN THE PUBLIC IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION -- I
MADE MY FIRST.
TRIP TO CAPITOL HILL IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE INTO A
STATE LEGISLATURE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND I'M ONE OF THE
ODD CEOS I THINK WHO.
LIKES.
THIS.
I LIKE DEALING WITH THE MEDIA I
LIKE DEALING IN THE POLITICAL
SPACE IT'S NOT ALWAYS PLEASANT --
BUT IT ISN'T DEMOCRACY ON THE
MARCH SO -- I'M HOPING TO SEE A
LOT OF YOU PART OF THAT WILL BE
ON YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SEE ME --
BUT I AM NO STRANGER TO THE
PROCESS AND I UNDERSTAND.
THE CLOSE CONNECTION BETWEEN.
UTILITY REGULATION THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO.
I HOPE NOT TO BE A STRANGER THAT
WOULD SAY THAT.
ON THE ISSUE OF TRUST YOU KNOW.
HOW DO YOU BUILD TRUST THERE'S A
COUPLE WAYS YOU DO THIS THE
FIRST THING IS SAY WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO AND DO IT?
RIGHT I MEAN THAT'S TELL THAT TO
MY DAD HAD TO SAY WHICH I HAVE
IT HERE TO JUST TELL THE TRUTH
AS FAST AS YOU CAN.
AND SO THAT'S PART OF TRUST TELL
THE TRUTH -- IF SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENS [inaudible]
OWNER.
DON'T COVERED UP.
CONDUCT YOUR BUSINESS IN A WAY
THAT YOU CAN BE PROUD OF AND
WE'VE HAD SOME INSTANCES OF
THINGS THE NOBODY CAN BE PROUD
OF AND I THINK IT'S THAT SIMPLE
METAL BUT THINK WE TEND OVER
COMPLICATE THINGS THE THINGS
LIKE TRUST.
ARE YOU GOING TO DO SAID YOU
GOTTA DO DID YOU MAKE SENSE WHEN
YOU SAID IT DID YOU SOCIALIZE
THE IDEA AND THEN DID YOU DO.
SO IF I TELL YOU I'M GONNA DO
THE BEST I CAN TO PREVENT A FIRE
AGAIN YOU CAN COUNT ON IT BEING
TRUE NOW WHETHER I WILL SUCCEED
OR NOT IS A DIFFERENT QUESTION.
BUT I THINK THAT'S HOW WE
REBUILD TRUST AND I KNOW IT'S
GOING TO TAKE AWHILE -- WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED THIS THIS IS
ABOUT A SET OF BEHAVIORS -- A
SET OF COMMITMENTS WE MAKE EVERY
DAY HERE'S A WE'RE GONNA DO OUR
BUSINESS.
AND WE GET A LINE GOING TO FIX
IT.
THERE WILL BE PLENTY OF
CHALLENGES -- I TELL YOU WHAT
I'M FOCUSED ON FOCUSED IN THE
SHORT TERM AT THE MALL.
SO I'VE BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON THE
WILD SIDE FIRE SAFETY PLAN.
AND YOU'LL HAVE TO FORGIVE ME
THERE ARE SO MANY ACRONYMS
FLYING AROUND ON THIS THAT I'M
NOT SURE I CAN KEEP ALL STRAIGHT.
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING --
PARTICULARLY THE INSPECTION AND
REPAIR WORK.
WHICH IS A TREMENDOUSLY LARGE
TASK IN A VERY ROBUST PROCESS SO
I'M THINKING ABOUT THE SHORT
TERM AT THE MOMENT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE FIXED --
ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES HERE AND
SEVERAL MAYORS UP TALK TO ONE OF
THE ISSUES WE HAVE IS HOOKING UP
NEW CUSTOMERS -- AND TAKES WEEKS
OR MONTHS THAT THOSE KIND OF
THINGS OUT TO BE FIXED BUT FIRST
THINGS FIRST.
A WILDFIRE SAFETY AND THEN WE'LL
GET TO EVERYTHING ELSE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT. TO ME I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR FOR BEING
HERE ESPECIALLY SO EARLY IN TWO
YEAR TENURE.
SO I REPRESENT -- THE SANTA ROSA
AREA.
AND WHILE P. JEANNIE WAS NOT
INTO IMPLICATED IN THAT
PARTICULAR FIRE ELSEWHERE
REPRESENT MENDOCINO COUNTY.
AND BELIEVE SOME OF YOUR
EQUIPMENT WAS INVOLVED IN THAT
FOR OUR FIRES THERE.
AS WELL AS OTHERS -- IN TWO
THOUSAND AFTER TWO THOUSAND TEN
THE SAN BRUNO PIPELINE EXPLOSION
HELPED IDENTIFY SOME OF THE
VICTIMS OF THAT.
IDENTIFY THE VICTIMS AND MY
FIRE'S.
AND THEN IDENTIFIED VICTIMS AT
PARADISE [inaudible]
I'M TIRED.
OF IDENTIFYING VICTIMS.
BUT ALL OF THOSE.
HAVE A LINK [inaudible] TO
UTILITY.
I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT AFTER THE
SAN BRUNO EXPLOSION IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN THAT THE
COMPANY MIGHT HAVE TAKEN
APPROACH.
WOW IF OUR GAS LINES ARE LIKE
THIS MAYBE WE OUGHT TO BE
LOOKING AT EVERYTHING.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT HAPPENED.
IF IT DID -- CERTAINLY WASN'T
PUBLICIZED.
SO AS WE GO IN TO YOUR TENURE
AND AS YOU ARE INSPECTING.
ALL OF THESE ALL OF THESE
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF LINES
THERE.
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING [inaudible]
BECAUSE I THINK CAN WE COULD
MISTER MISTER GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN TO REALLY DO
THAT ON A BROADER BASIS.
AND I JUST WANNA I JUST WANT TO
KNOW THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE OPERATION OF
UTILITY.
WELL FIRST OF ALL LET ME SAY
SORRY TO HAVE GIVEN YOU THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES TO IDENTIFY BODIES
AS A TERRIBLE.
AND MARK MY EXPOSURE TO THOSE
THREE PLACES THAT THAT IS JUST
OF NOT.
I'LL NEVER GET OVER SO JUST.
AND I THINK YOUR ASSESSMENT IS
CORRECT -- I THINK WHEN SAN
BRUNO HAPPENED.
ALL EVERYBODY WAS FOCUSED ON
FIXING THAT.
AND SO FIXED A SYMPTOM A BIG
SYMPTOM BUT MAYBE IT AND FOCUS
ON THE DISEASE.
OF AND I THINK A LITTLE BEHIND
ON THE ELECTRIC SIDE I THINK.
THINK EMPIRICALLY YOU COULD
DEMONSTRATE THIS -- ARE WE
LOOKING AT EVERYTHING.
WE'RE LOOKING AT EVERYTHING NOW
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT A LEVEL OF
GRANULARITY THAT I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE INDUSTRY IS
DONE MAYBE SAN DIEGO BUT WE'RE
LOOKING AT EVERYTHING AND WE
WILL LOOK AT EVERYTHING.
AND WE WILL LOOK AT THE GAS AND
ELECTRIC SYSTEMS AT THE SAME
TIME.
SO THEY'LL BE NO DIMINUTION AN
EFFORT IN THE GAS SIDE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE GAS SIDE
PERFORMANCE TODAY IS PRETTY GOOD.
YOU KNOW THEY THEY GOT GOT IT
RIGHT THERE DOING PRETTY WELL
THEY HAVE OCCASIONAL HICK UPS
THAT.
KIND OF EMBARRASSING BUT BUT THE
ELECTRIC SIDE WERE BEHIND WHERE
THEY ARE.
ON THE GAS SIDE AND WE'LL CATCH
UP.
MESSAGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
FOR COMING TO THIS COMMITTEE --
ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES THAT THIS
COMMITTEE.
HAS BEEN DEALING WITH IS THE THE
CHANGING NATURE OF THE
CALIFORNIA -- ENERGY -- INDUSTRY
ESPECIALLY WITH THE GROWING --
PROPORTION OF ENERGY BEING
PROCURED BY -- COMMITTEE CHOICE
AGGREGATORS.
IT'S MUCH MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
46%.
OF P. GENIES ELECTRICITY LOAD IS
PROCURED BY.
KIMI CHOICE AGGREGATORS AS RAY
PAIRS ARE OPTING OUT OF PRIVATE
ELECTRICITY SERVICE IN FAVOR OF
THE LOCAL.
LOCAL CONTROL PUBLIC PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
AND SO.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS YOU KNOW AS
WE'RE AS YOU STARTED OFF TALKING
ABOUT SAFETY BEING YOUR NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY AND I THINK.
YOU KNOW THE CONCERNS THAT THE
THE QUESTIONS RAISED BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
JUST EMPHASIZE THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY IS OUR NUMBER ONE CONCERN.
WOOD -- NARROWING P. GENIES
SCOPE OF RESPONSIBILITIES TO
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION --
ALLOW PEAS YOU NEED TO FOCUS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY.
AND GREAT MANAGEMENT.
SO I HAVE HEARD THE TERM
COMMUNITY AGGREGATION.
THAT'S ABOUT AS DEEP AS I GO BUT
THERE WASN'T REALLY A QUESTION --
THERE ARE VERY LARGE COMPANIES
IN THIS COUNTRY IN THIS REGION
IN THIS CITY.
THERE ARE WELL MANAGED
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A QUESTION OF
WOULD IT HELP.
PGA ANY TO SHED SOME ASSETS --
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE GOING TO
FOCUS ON OTHER THINGS -- I THINK.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO MANAGE ALL
THOSE THINGS.
HISTORICALLY GENERATION
TRANSMISSION.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
MANAGEMENT CAPABILITY QUESTION.
THAT -- WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
FOCUS ON ALL THESE THINGS NOW I
DON'T KNOW.
WHAT THE BEST ANSWER FINANCIALLY
FOR CUSTOMERS IS ME MY RIGHT
BEHIND SAFETY FOR ME IS CUSTOMER
IMPACT?
I AM PRO CONSUMER ALSO AND THAT.
OFTEN HARD TO BE IN THIS
BUSINESS BUT I AM BUT YOU KNOW A
LOT OF I KNOW PEOPLE ARE
STUDYING THINGS LIKE.
DIVEST OF GENERATION OR
MUNICIPAL LIES.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T MANAGE OUR
BUSINESS I THINK THE BETTER
THING FOR US TO DO IS
DEMONSTRATE TO WE CAN MANAGE THE
BUSINESS.
WELL AGAIN YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU'RE.
NEW TO CALIFORNIA BUT CCA'S IS A
ACRONYM THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
HEARING A LOT ABOUT.
AND I THINK IT'S A IT'S NOT JUST --
TO NATO A HYPOTHETICAL BUT IT IS.
YOU KNOW ALMOST HALF OF P.
JEANNIE -- THE PC PROJECTED 80%.
I BELIEVE -- IN THE NEAR FUTURE --
AND SO -- YEAH I A WAY WHICH IS
TO I I BELIEVE THAT.
THIS IS GONNA BE ONE OF OUR
FOCUSES ON WHETHER THE
TRADITIONAL ROLE OF UTILITIES --
HOW THAT WOULD -- INVOLVED WITH
THE RISE OF THESE CCA'S.
AND SO MAYBE I CAN COME BACK IN
TWO WEEKS WHEN I'M TWO WEEKS
SMARTER.
QUESTION AS OF TODAY I CANNOT
THANK YOU -- THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
WELCOME -- AYE AYE YEAH.
I JOIN WITH THE CHAIRS COMMENTS --
ABOUT THE VERY DEEP CONCERN.
ABOUT WHAT PGA ANY IS DOING IN
RESPONSE. TO WHAT THEY CAUSED IN
RESPONSE TO THE BANKRUPTCY.
I DON'T AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
ABOUT THE STATE'S ROLE AND LACK
OF ACTION.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE FALL
TEST GO SQUARELY ON PGA ANY.
I ATE THERE ARE NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT YOU'VE SAID THAT -- HERE
TODAY.
YOU YOU YOU COMMENTED THAT
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO CLEAN FOR
THE CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE.
THE PGA ANY [inaudible]
YET. FOR TV A THEY ARE ON THEIR
WEBSITE THEY TALK ABOUT.
THE THE FACT THAT THE TRACK
RECORD FALLS SHORT OF WHAT P.
GENIES CUSTOMERS DESERVE.
THERE'S A LACK OF SOLAR AND WIND
POWER ON TVA'S COAL DEPENDENT
SYSTEM.
CALL MADE UP MORE THAN A QUARTER
OF TVA'S PORTFOLIO LAST YEAR
WITH SOLAR AND WIND ACCOUNTING
FOR JUST 3%.
ACCORDING TO THE COMPANY'S
WEBSITE.
THAT CONCERNS ME I UNDERSTAND
THERE WAS A REDUCTION IN COAL.
DURING YOUR TENURE I RECOGNIZE
THAT.
BUT CALIFORNIA IS VERY DIFFERENT.
THAN.
THEN WHERE YOU CAME FROM.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
HAS QUITE A FEW HEDGE FUND --
MEMBERS AND TOO FEW CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MY CALL BECAUSE ASKED ABOUT
CCA'S.
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT TO KNOW
ABOUT THAT AND IF WE HAD MORE
BOARD MEMBERS WHO WERE.
FROM CALIFORNIA ORDER STOOD WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA.
THEN THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING.
THE BOARD MEMBERS WOULD BE
CONCERNED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR NEW CEO KNEW ALL ABOUT IT.
I KNOW THAT IN THE SHORT TEN
YEARS SINCE YOU HAVE JUST BEEN
APPOINTED WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT
FOR YOU TO KNOW EVERYTHING.
I GET IT.
YOU ALSO SAID.
THE YOU BELIEVE IN EARNED
REDEMPTION FOR PGA ANY. ONE OF
MY QUESTIONS WOULD BE.
WHAT DID P. JENNY DO WRONG?
THAT YOU KNOW ABOUT.
AND THAT YOU WILL LEARN YOU WILL
USE AS A LEARNING TOOL.
DURING YOUR TENURE THAT'S COMING
UP.
IN RESPONSE TO MY COLLEAGUE.
YOU TALKED WE TALKED ABOUT TRUST.
AND YOU SAID SAY WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO AND DO IT.
I I I WANT TO KNOW.
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO?
SO THAT WE CAN THEN COME BACK
AND SAY WHETHER YOU DID IT OR
NOT.
THIS IS TOO IMPORTANT I DON'T
WANT MY COLLEAGUE TO GO IDENTIFY
ANYMORE BODIES.
I JOIN WITH HIM TO MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES ON THIS CONFERENCE
COME CONFERENCE.
COMMITTEE ON THE WILDFIRES NIGHT
LEARNED MORE THAN I EVER WANTED
TO LEARN ABOUT THIS.
IT ISN'T SOMETHING THAT I
EXPERIENCE IN MY COMMUNITY BUT I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING PART
OF THAT.
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE RELIVING
THIS WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT THE
LESSONS LEARNED ARE SO MY
QUESTION.
IN ONE LAST COMMENT.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE GAS LINES I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE ASKED ABOUT
THAT [inaudible]
AND YOUR RESPONSE WAS THEY'RE
PRETTY GOOD.
THERE'S A COMMERCIAL OUT NOW.
ABOUT.
THE DOCTORS -- AND WHETHER
THEY'RE PRETTY GOOD AND YOU COME
IN AND THAT SERGEANT CERTAIN
SURGEON COMES IN TO SEE YOU AND
YOU'RE READY FOR SURGERY AND YOU
LOOK UP YOU SAY.
DOCTOR WHAT MY CHANCES YOU SAYS
THEY'RE PRETTY GOOD I THINK.
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH NOT ON THE
COMMERCIAL AND NOT HERE BECAUSE
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO TO
WORK ON POLICY THAT'S GOING TO
PROTECT.
THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT ARE
SERVED IN THIS CASE BY KEY G.
ANY.
SO MY QUESTION THEN IS JUST AS
WE WERE DOWN SKATE PRESIDENT
JUST AS WE WOULD ASK ANYONE ELSE
COMING IN. TO SUCH AN IMPORTANT
POSITION OF POWER.
WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS?
I DO WANT TO HEAR.
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT ONE ANSWER COULD
BE?
I'M GOING TO TALK TO PEOPLE FIND
OUT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO GO.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A HUNDRED
DAYS TOO LATE.
I THINK IF WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
THE NEXT ONE HUNDRED DAYS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
BECAUSE IT WOULD THEY WOULD NOT
HAVE BROUGHT TO WIN UNLESS YOU
CAME IN AND WITH THIS WEALTH OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU SHARED WITH
US.
AND THE WE'VE READ ABOUT.
BUT WHAT IS IT THAT WILL HAPPEN
NOW IN THE NEXT ONE HUNDRED DAYS
THE NEXT SIX MONTHS.
BECAUSE I FOR ONE WANT TO KNOW.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU DID IT.
WHEN WE COME BACK TO EVALUATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PERHAPS I CAN START WITH A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT TV.
I THINK HERE YOU PROBABLY EXPECT
YOUR UTILITIES TO FOLLOW THE
LAWS OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
RULES OF THE CPUC.
AND THE SAME IS TRUE TV ATV IS A
CREDIT AS A CREATURE OF A
FEDERAL STATUTE.
PASSED IN NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
AND THE TV A ACCESS THE PRIMARY.
THE PRIMARY OBJECTIVE OF TVA IS
TO PRODUCE ELECTRICITY AT THE
LOWEST FEASIBLE RATE.
THAT'S THAT IS THE EXACT
LANGUAGE AND IS SUPPLEMENTED BY
SAYING.
WHEN YOU ADD RESOURCES YOU HAVE
TO ADD THE LOWEST COST RESOURCE
FOR YOU GET THE LOWER SYSTEM
COST?
AND SO THAT IS HOW THEY ENDED UP
WITH THE SYSTEM THEY HAD WHICH
WAS COLD DEPEND.
NOW WHAT HAPPENED IN MY TENURE
THERE AND A LITTLE BIT BEFORE
THAT AS WE WERE TIRED A LOT OF
THAT PLACE TO WITH SOME NUCLEAR
SOME GAS.
MORE HYDRO AND MORE RENEWAL.
SO TODAY.
TVA 60% NOT AMENDING HEADER G..
AND THE CARBON FOOTPRINT IS KIND
AND HAPPENED TO BE 70% REDUCED
IN FIVE YEARS.
AND SO TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AS
THE LOWEST COST OPTION.
WAS ACTUALLY A I THINK A PRETTY
GOOD BODY OF WORK BY THE PEOPLE
THERE.
THE POLICY HERE IS DIFFERENT THE
POLICY HERE IS CLEANER AND
GREENER.
THE THE TV A TV A ACT COULDN'T
BE CLEARER ABOUT WHAT.
TVA WAS POSTED IT -- THERE'S A
PRETTY GOOD.
IS A STANDARD LINE OF MINE I
WILL NEVER USE IT AGAIN.
I'VE SEEN THE COMMERCIAL.
BUT WHEN I EVALUATE PEOPLE
INTERNALLY.
PRETTY GOOD IS ABOUT AS GOOD AS
I'M EVER GOING TO TELL HIM
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT.
TO GIVE TOO MUCH CREDIT -- SO
BUT THAT'S SLIP ON MY PART.
CELEBRITY ADDRESS THE GAS SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE ITS TOP QUARTILE IN
THE INDUSTRY IN MANY REGARDS
INCLUDING IN THE SAFETY PIECE.
SO THE GUESTS BUSINESS THE GAS
SYSTEM HERE IS ROBUST WELL
MANAGE THE RISKS ARE IDENTIFIED
IN MITIGATED SO.
IT'S WELL BEYOND PRETTY GOOD
IT'S IT'S IT'S RIGHT UP THERE IN
THE TOP QUARTILE OF GAS SYSTEMS
IN THE COUNTRY SO.
THE LESSONS LEARNED -- WILL PART
OF THIS I DISCUSSED WITH HER
COLLEAGUES YOU HAVE TO IDENTIFY
THE DISEASE NOT JUST THE
SYMPTOMS.
AND THE DISEASE.
WAS LACK OF KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE
CONDITION OF THE ASSETS
[inaudible]
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW IN SEPTEMBER --
HAPPEN IS BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
THE CONDITION OF THE PIPE DIDN'T
KNOW HOW LONG IT BEEN THERE ALL
THAT SO THAT'S WHY IT HAPPENED
SO.
THE REAL LESSON LEARNED IS
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THAT'S THE LAST.
WE ARE ACCOUNTABLE EVERYDAY FOR
PROVIDING GAS ELECTRIC SERVICE
AND OTHER THINGS TO PEOPLE IN A
SAFE RELIABLE AFFORDABLE MATTER
THAT IS THE ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND WHEN YOU STRAY FROM THAT.
YOU HAVE EVENTS LIKE SAM ROAD --
WE GET DISTRACTED WE FOCUS ON I
DON'T KNOW WHAT.
BUT THE FIRST THING I'M GOING TO
DO IS BRING AN INTENSE FOCUS.
BACK TO THE FUNDAMENTALS OF
OPERATING UTILITY SYSTEM.
RIGHT CLEAR ROLES CLEAR
ACCOUNTABILITY CLEAR STANDARD OF
WHAT GOOD LOOKS LIKE.
AND I'VE ALREADY SEEN OUR NUMBER
PLACES WHERE.
WE'RE NOT EVEN PRETTY GOOD --
THAT WE LAGGED THE INDUSTRY IN
SOME IMPORTANT.
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS I'M GOING.
TO USE INDUSTRY BENCHMARK TOP
QUARTILE PERFORMANCES ARE
MEASURE.
SO EVERYTHING WE DO AN ELECTRIC
GAS BUSINESSES MEASURE.
AND PEOPLE KEEP TRACK OF THE
INDUSTRY AND WE'RE GOING TO
DRIVE TOWARD TOP QUARTILE
PERFORMANCE AND EVERY ONE OF
THOSE -- WE HAVE TO GET A LOT OF
INTERNAL PROCESS SEES AND OTHER
THINGS STRAIGHTENED OUT -- BUT
TO ME THIS IS AN EXERCISE.
IN RETURNING TO MASTERY OF THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF THE BUSINESS
BECAUSE A VERY FUNDAMENTAL
BUSINESS -- SO THAT'S LIKE THE
FIRST YEAR.
RIGHT. THOUSAND VISION LONG TERM --
CLEAN GREEN AFFORDABLE RELIABLE
SAFE.
AND A SERVICE PROVIDER THE
CUSTOMERS CAN BE PROUD OF THAT'S
IT SEEMS TO ME TO BE A GOOD
PLACE TO BE AND A HARD PLACE FOR
US TO GET.
IT IN.
THE PLANS AND I KNOW THERE'S A
RESPONSE TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
YOU TALKED ABOUT ON THE WILD
FIRE SAFETY PLAN.
INSPECTION AND REPAIR BE VERY
ROBUST.
VISUALLY INSPECTING ALL
EQUIPMENT WHICH WAS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF MILES.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MILES
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
EQUIPMENT EQUIPMENT. HUNDRED
THOU HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PIECES OF A QUICK.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PIECES
OF EQUIPMENT.
WHAT IS THE COST ESTIMATES? FOR
THAT -- FOR THAT ACTIVITY THE
RANGERS SIX HUNDRED THE NINE
HUNDRED MILLION.
YEAH AND I ASSUME THAT INCLUDES
HIRING.
MORE MORE STAFF MORE EMPLOYEES.
YES WE HAVE.
IN FACT ABOUT TAPPED OUT ON THE
WESTERN PART OF THE COUNTRY TREE
TRIMMERS INSPECTORS.
WE HAVE EVERY RESOURCE WE CAN
FIND AT WORK OUT THERE DOING
THIS.
AND WHERE WILL THE MONEY COME
FROM -- WELL.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION -- I
THINK INITIALLY IT'S COMING OUT
OF THE TV A COPPERS I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE RULES ARE IN RECOVERY
OR ANY OTHERS TVA COFFERS.
IN THE STOCK AROUND THE TV A
COVERAGE THE PGA ANY COVERAGE I
MAY HAVE SAID TV NAY BECAUSE IT
DID AND I WAS I WAS EXCITED
ABOUT THAT.
THEY DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE ANY
MONEY THERE SO.
THANK YOU FOR FOR YOUR YOUR
HONEST ANSWERS A I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO COMING BACK -- TO SEE
EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE -- BUT
AGAIN I DO WANT.
TO STATE.
THAT THE STATEMENT.
GIVEN BY OUR CHAIR AT THE VERY
BEGINNING.
THE VERY HARSH.
I THINK.
EXPRESSES A SENTIMENT OF SO MANY.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE AND IN THIS ENTIRE
PROCESS.
AND HAVE LISTENED TO PGA ANY SET
RIGHT WHERE YOU ARE.
AND TALK TO US ABOUT HOW THEY
HAVE DONE EVERYTHING THEY COULD.
SO I I TO WANT TO ALIGN MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
CHAIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WANTED TO BE STRAIGHT TALKER
PAULA JESSICA CAME OFF AS HARSH --
BUT I THINK THAT -- NO WELL
WE'RE FEELING AND SENSING AS A
GREAT DEAL OF PRESSURE AND
WEIGHT THAT'S ON ALL OF US AND
NO THE UTILITY INDUSTRY IS VERY
VITAL. TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA VERY NECESSARY VERY
IMPORTANT.
WE WANTED TO WORK.
ON BUT IN THIS LAST ROUND THE
QUESTION I THINK THAT -- IT'S
SAFE TO SAY THAT.
WHERE THE MONEY'S COMING FROM AS
WORD ALWAYS COMES FROM?
AND IT WILL PROBABLY FALL ON THE
REPAIRS MORE THAN LIKELY --
THERE MAY BE SOME OTHER
CONFIGURATIONS OF HOW THAT
ULTIMATELY TAKES FORM BUT I'VE
YET TO HEAR A SEE HOW THE PIE
GETS CUT.
INTO MANY OTHER -- DIRECTIONS
OTHER THAN HAVING REPAIR.
CONTRIBUTIONS.
SO DOLLARS.
IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE
HAVEN'T.
TALKED ABOUT TODAY IS -- SO I'VE
NEVER BEEN IN BANKRUPTCY BUT
I'VE TRIED TO COLLECT MONEY FROM
PEOPLE OR BANKRUPTCY IN AND
BANKRUPTCY IS A TOOL BASICALLY.
FOR THE COMPANY WHICH IN THIS
CASE IS [inaudible]
P. JEANNIE. TO NOT HAVE A JUDGE
IS GOING TO MAKE UP THE DECEIT
OR MAYBE MORE THAN ONE JUDGE IN
THIS CASE I DON'T NOT SURE BUT A
JUDGE IS GOING TO MAKE THE
DECISION ON ALLOW YOU TO DO SOME
THINGS -- AND THAT IT THAT MEANS
CONTRACTS POWER PURCHASE
AGREEMENTS -- THERE ARE A LOT OF
A NEW WILL GOALS THAT REQUIRE --
POWER PURCHASE AGREEMENTS WITH
SOLAR AND WIND.
HYDRO.
GEO THERMAL [inaudible]
BATTERY STORAGE [inaudible]
AND SO.
WOULD YOU TOUCH MAYBE ON WHAT
YOUR THOUGHT PROCESSES WITH THE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT YOU'RE GONNA
BE DOING WITH.
AND THE JUDGE.
AND THE OF MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE RELIANT ON THOSE
PURCHASE POWER AGREEMENTS AND
MANY COMPANIES OUT THERE THAT
HAVE INVESTED.
MILLIONS AND TENS OF MILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA IN.
TRYING -- TO MAKE OUR SYSTEM
MORE GREEN -- WHAT WHAT'S YOUR
TAKE ON HOW THOSE MANY OF THOSE --
ARE IN OUR COMMUNITIES I KNOW
THAT.
TO MY COLLEAGUE IN THE SECOND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT -- HAS THE GEO
THERMAL WHICH ARE CONTRACTS WITH
YOU WE HAVE HYDRO WE HAVE BIO
MASS WE HAVE WIND WE HAVE SOLAR
WE AND IT'S ALL THROUGH THE
STATE.
AND THOSE ARE ALL PURCHASE POWER
AGREEMENTS THAT ARE -- AT RISK --
I BELIEVE IN IN A IN A
OPPORTUNITY WERE A JUDGE AND A
COMPANY CAN SAY HEY LOOK WE WERE
PAYING I KNOW IN SOME OF THOSE
EARLY CONTRACTS.
FOR SOLAR WAS TWENTY TWO CENTS.
FOR THIRTY YEARS AND NOW YOU CAN
BUY SOLAR FOR ABOUT THREE CENTS
AND SO.
WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE WHAT
DO YOU WHAT DO YOU SEE WHERE IT
WORLD WORD YOU SAY THE COPY
OBVIOUSLY YOU YOU'RE IN THE
BUSINESS OF SAVING THIS CAUGHT
ME AT THE SAME TIME?
RIGHT WHICH THAT IS PART OF YOUR
ROLE AS THE AS THE HEAD OF THE
COMPANY AS WELL SO COULD YOU
MAYBE ADDRESS WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
ARE ON ON THOSE THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF EMPLOYEES AND PEOPLE THAT
WORK.
OF FOR THOSE -- ASSETS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE AS WELL.
SO YOU START OUT BY DEFINING
BANKRUPTCY.
RIGHT WHICH IS A PROCESS TO GET
ALL YOUR CLAIM TO ONE SPOT A ONE
COURT WITH ONE JUDGE.
FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH YOU CAN PAY
AND THEN ALLOCATED THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE BASIC PROCESS.
AS PART OF THIS.
CONTRACTS ARE REVIEWABLE.
AND I AM NOT EVADING YOUR
QUESTION OR ANY OF THOSE THINGS
I'M NOT A AND WE THERE'S NO
DECISION AND NO CLOSE TO A
DECISION ON THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE JUST WE KNOW IT'S OUT THERE.
THERE IS A DISPUTE BETWEEN.
THE C. P. WATER OF IS A DISPUTE
THERE'S SOME CONFUSION ABOUT
WHO'S ACTUALLY IN CHARGE OF THIS
QUESTION THE FOR THE CP YOU SEE
THE BANKRUPTCY COURT -- I DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT.
AND I DON'T YOU KNOW I'M. FOR BE
IT FOR ME TO GET IN THE WAY OF
YOUR TRYING TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION BUT I THINK WE TRIED --
TO ESTABLISH AT THE ONSET THAT
WE WERE NOT GOING.
TO DRIFT INTO THE THE BANKRUPTCY
ISSUES FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
AND SO -- NO THAT'S OKAY -- BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
THERE'S A RECOGNITION THAT SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU TALK
ABOUT OUR OUR PART OF THE
CONVERSATION AND THOSE ARE YET
TO BE DETERMINED BUT IF YOU HAVE
SOME WELL WITHOUT GETTING DEEPER
INTO THIS -- I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE CONTRACTS SO
I CAN THIS IS NOT A CASUAL.
ISSUE FOR ME BUT WITH IS JUST
THAT WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO THAT
POINT YEAH [inaudible]
THE TERM.
DOCTOR WHAT.
YEAH JUST JUST A QUESTION YOU
SAID THAT I THINK WAS ASKED ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES ASKED YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THIS GOING TO COST TO DO.
THE INSPECTIONS OF EVERYTHING --
WAS AT THAT WAS JUST THE THAT
SIX HUNDRED AND NINE HUNDRED
MILLION OF SUGGESTING JUST TO DO
ALL THE INSPECTIONS.
OR YOU TALK ABOUT REPAIRS AS
WELL BECAUSE WE DON'T YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO FIND
NOW SO THAT IS THE INSPECTION
AND REPAIRS BOTH -- AND THAT
INCLUDES LIKE TREE TREMAYNE AND
AND OTHER THINGS AS WELL OR IS
THERE YET SO THERE ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL LAYERS THAT THE
WEATHER'S ALWAYS I'M SORRY I
MEAN -- YOU KNOW THERE'S ALWAYS.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WE SHOULD
CALL THE TREE TRIMMING ITSELF
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
AND I THINK WE HAVE DOUBLE OUR
EFFORT IN THAT REGARD STARTING
IN LAST YEAR.
THE SIXTY NINE HUNDRED HAS TO DO
WITH THE NEW PROGRAMS WE PUT IN
PLACE.
AND THEY ARE INSPECTION AND
REPAIR.
AND THEY INVOLVE THE VISUAL BY A
TRAINED OBSERVER BUT ALSO WERE
USING DRONES.
IT TURNS OUT THE DRONES CAN SEE
A LOT BETTER THAN HUMANS CAN
BECAUSE YOU CAN GET THE ANGLES --
AND THIS THE DRONE WORK AND THE
HIGH RESOLUTION OF THE PICTURES.
AND THEN WE HAVE.
LARGER ROOMS OF TRAINED
ENGINEERS AND OTHERS WHO CAN
LOOK AT THESE PICTURES AND SAY.
THERE'S A WASHER MISSING THERE
THERE'S A COTTER PIN THAT'S BAND.
SO IT'S BOTH INSPECTION AND
REPAIR AND AND IT'S A VERY HIGH
TECH KIND OF PROCESS
[inaudible]
THANKS.
FOR THIS MAYOR.
VICE CHAIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SHOULD YOU COMING IN.
AND TALKING WITH ASIDE.
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT IT IS IN A VERY DIFFICULT.
SPOT.
AND THAT YOU ARE NEW -- BUT
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY SOME.
UNDERCURRENTS OF REAL CONCERN
HERE -- AND I WOULD LIKE WITHOUT
GETTING INTO ENOUGH AYE STRAIGHT
INTO THE BANKRUPTCY AS PART OF
THIS.
HELP HELP ME OUT OF THAT.
HOLE.
I PART OF BUILDING TRUST I THINK
IS TO GET AN UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE ERA LEADERS.
VISION AND IMAGINATION FOR WHAT
PGA ANY IS GOING TO BE.
I'M NOT SURE THAT YOU CAN BE
FAULTED FOR WHAT HAPPENED.
YESTERDAY -- YOU HAVE A
CHALLENGE TO REALLY GET WRAPPED
AROUND TODAY WHAT'S GOING ON BUT
IF YOU'RE HERE FOR A WHILE IT'S
GOING TO BE THE TOMORROW THAT I
THINK.
ALL OF US ARE GOING TO WANT TO
BE.
ENCOURAGED THAT THERE WILL BE A
A PGA ANY THAT IS IMAGINED AND
ACTUALLY.
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT AN
IMPROVED PERHAPS THAN BEFORE
WHAT DO YOU IMAGINE WHAT DO YOU
ATTEMPTING TO TRY. TO DO AS THE
PERSON AT THE TOP OF THE PYRAMID.
TO REDESIGN AND PERHAPS
MODERNIZE AND REIMAGINE WHAT.
PGA ANY IS GONNA LOOK LIKE GO GO
I MEAN WHAT WE'RE NINETEEN YEARS
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
WHERE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
ON THE PLANET.
AND WE LITERALLY HAVE AN
ELECTRICITY GRID.
THAT I THINK IS SLOWLY
DISINTEGRATING AND IT'S IT'S A
LOT OF CONCERN FOR MANY OF US.
WHAT DO YOU SEE THE ROLE AS P.
GENIE IN THE BIG PICTURE AND
WHAT IT IN IN CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTRICITY?
SUPPLY.
AND WHAT DO YOU WHAT IS THE
IMAGINATION GOING TO LOOK LIKE
WHAT IS THE NEW P. JEANNIE.
LOOK LIKE WHETHER IT COMES OUT
OF BANKRUPTCY AYE.
THAT'S THAT'S ANOTHER MATTER.
BUT WHAT WHAT'S YOUR VISION YOUR
IMAGINATION AND YOUR HEART FELT
DESIRE. TO FIX.
HELLO FIRST OF ALL -- WHERE WE
ARE AT THE MOMENT IS SURVIVAL
MODE? TO BE FRANK ABOUT THIS
RIGHT SO.
BEFORE I CAN IMAGINE TOO HARD I
GOTTA THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
AROUND TO BE IMAGINE RIGHT.
I HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT THE
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE CAN I TELL YOU
WHAT I THINK MAY I THINK IT
LOOKS LIKE A LOT OF MICRO GIVE
GRADES.
MUCH MORE DISTRIBUTED GENERATION
THIS.
THE FIND A GOOD FOR P. GENIES
BUSINESS MODEL AS WE KNOW IT
TODAY BUT THIS IS REALITY OF
CHANGE AND TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATION.
I THINK THE TRANSMISSION
BACKBONE IN THIS COUNTRY WHICH
IS SERVED US WELL.
A IS ALSO ONE OF THE BIGGEST
VULNERABILITIES WE HAVE. TO THE
EXTENT YOU CAN LOCALIZE THINGS.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE CONTINUED
COST REDUCTIONS IN STORAGE WHEN
YOU CAN COMBINED SOLAR WITH
LOCAL STORAGE -- MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE SO I SEE A MUCH MORE
DISPERSED WORLD -- MUCH MORE
LOCALIZED.
SOME CENTRALIZED YOU'RE STILL
GOING TO NEED SOME SUPER
HIGHWAYS IN THE SYSTEM.
I THINK LESS AND LESS OF THAT
OVER TIME IS WAS GONNA LOOK LIKE.
IN THAT CONTEXT.
HOW DO YOU SEE?
ESSENTIALLY THIS
DECENTRALIZATION AND
LOCALIZATION.
PLAY OUT WITH RESPECT TO
RELIABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY.
WE SAY HERE.
THAT PARAMOUNT IN OUR POLICY IS
RELIABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY.
I THINK UNFORTUNATELY FROM TIME
TO TIME WE PRODUCE POLICIES THAT
ACTUALLY.
REDUCE RELIABILITY AND SPIKE.
COSTS.
I CONCUR WITH YOU THAT I THINK
THIS -- DECENTRALIZATION AND AND
THESE MICROGRAMS AYE HI I THINK
THAT HAS SOME SOME REALITY THERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE CHALLENGES
ARE FOR RELIABILITY AND FOR
PORTABILITY IN THAT CONTEXT?
THERE'S A REASON WE HAVE THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE TODAY.
BECAUSE IT WAS THE CHEAPEST WAY
TO DO IT THE MOST ECONOMICAL AND
RELIABLE WAY TO DO IT.
WHEN WE BUILT A SYSTEM IT
OPERATED OVER THE LAST? HUNDRED
YEARS FIFTY YEARS CENTRALIZATION.
ECONOMIES OF SCALE ALL THOSE
THINGS WORK -- THEY WORKED
MOSTLY BECAUSE OF THE LIMITS OF
TECHNOLOGY.
RIGHT THE HOW DO YOU SEND --
ELECTRICITY OVER LONG DISTANCES
WE HAD TO GO FROM DIRECT CURRENT
ALTERNATING CURRENT THOSE KIND
OF THING SO IT'S BEEN PRETTY
STATIC FOR A LONG TIME.
THE ADVENT OF TECHNOLOGY -- IT
OVER SOLAR PRICES ARE TODAY --
HE I THINK THIS WILL CHANGE I
THINK THERE'S ALWAYS A RISK OF
BEING ON THE FRONT EDGE OF THIS --
IT IS A FACT BUT IT'S A IT'S A
FACT.
TO THINK THE AVERAGE PGA ANY
RATE IS ABOUT TWENTY TWO CENTS
AVERAGE RATING TVA WAS NINE
CENTS.
NOW.
ED DIFFERENT THE SOCIAL
CONDITIONS AT ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENCES -- BUT PART OF THAT
HAS TO DO WITH THE POLICY HERE.
BUT YOU KNOW THE OTHER PART OF
THE POLICY GOING FORWARD AS IF
YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE PLANET
THEN YOU HAVE TO DO SOME OF
THESE THINGS TO GO MORE LOCAL
MORE DECENTRALIZED.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE WILL BE AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY YEARS.
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION I'D.
WANT TO CONTINUE IT WITH YOU AND
I THAT YOUR OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES -- I THINK WE'VE
GOT SOME REAL CHALLENGES LOOKING
AT WHAT THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
GRAY IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE AND I
THINK WE'RE KINDA HELTER SKELTER
RING IT.
AND I THINK WE'VE GOT TO BE
FOCUSED ON A LONG TERM AS MUCH
AS WE GET FOCUSED.
ON THE FACT THAT.
YOU'RE IN SURVIVAL MODE BUT I
APPRECIATE AT LEAST THE
EXPLANATION OF YOUR VISION
THANKS -- I GUESS I HAVE THAT
THE GAVEL AND WHO WANTED TO BE
RECOGNIZED -- MEMORIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WAS JUST SENT OVER THE NEWEST
HEADLINE PGA ANY CALLS CAMPFIRE.
CAL FIRE SAYS.
JUST CAME OUT TODAY PACIFIC GAS
ELECTRIC COMPANY IS BEING BLAMED
FOR SPARKING THE DEADLIEST AND
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE.
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
A NEW HEADLINE.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE COST OF
SIX HUNDRED TO NINE HUNDRED I
KNOW THE QUESTION WAS ASKED
ABOUT.
ULTIMATELY WHERE DOES IT COME
FROM.
BUT THE THE ANSWER THE RESPONSE
WAS CORRECT IT'S GOING TO
ULTIMATELY COME FROM THE RATE
PAYERS BUT MY QUESTION IS.
WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THE THE
COST SHOULD BE BORN.
NOT ONLY BY THE RATE PAYERS.
BUT ALSO BY THE SHAREHOLDERS.
OF PGA ANY -- THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN THE BANKRUPT.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WEAPON THE
BANKRUPTCY HOW MUCH OF THIS IS
PAID FOR BY WHOMEVER.
AND PART OF THAT WILL BE THE
SHAREHOLDERS.
WE'RE TALKING PROSPECTIVELY --
RIGHT.
THE RETROACTIVELY YES THE
BANKRUPTCY COURT IS LOOKING AT
THE PICTURE AND THEY WILL FIGURE
OUT ALL OF THOSE COSTS AND
FIGURE OUT HOW IT SCHOOL WHO'S
GOING TO GET PAID WHAT AND WILL
HAVE THE PROBLEMS JUST AS OF MY
COLLEAGUES TALKED ABOUT.
BUT PROSPECTIVELY.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
TO NINE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IS GOING TO BE SPENT ON THESE
ITEMS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT THE
INSPECTION REPAIR.
AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
AND THE COMMENT WAS MADE THAT
WHO WILL PAY.
WILL YOU MENTION FOR THE P.
JEANNIE COFFERS BUT IN THE JUST
THE RATE PAYERS.
MY QUESTION IS PROSPECT OF BILLY.
WE'RE LOOKING AT SIX HUNDRED TO
NINE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IT
WILL BE SPENT. TO RIGHT THE
WRONGS THAT LET THE PRIOR RUNS.
SHOULD IT ALL BE FROM THE RATE
PAYERS.
POCKETS OR SHOULD THE
SHAREHOLDERS.
ALSO PAY A PART OF THAT.
I THINK IF IS WRITING PREVIOUS
WRONGS SHAREHOLDERS SHOULD PAY
THEIR SHARE.
AND IN THE FUTURE.
WHEN THESE EXPENSES ARE MADE?
AND IT ALL FALLS ON THE RATE
PAYERS.
WOULD YOU AGREE THAT
SHAREHOLDERS.
SHOULD ALSO HAVE A SHARE.
IN PAYING FOR THIS.
YEAH IN THE INSTANT YOU HAVE
DESCRIBED YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
WAS CRITICAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR UP MORE
OF MORE OF A COMMENT.
TO GO BACK TO MY PREVIOUS
QUESTION ABOUT -- YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
THE BACK AND FORTH CONVERSATION
THAT'S GOING TO BE NEEDED
SEVERAL OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP TODAY.
WE UNDERSTAND AND I UNDERSTAND
VERY CLEARLY THAT WE MAY NOT
ALWAYS HAVE ACCESS TO YOU.
SO I HOPE THAT IN IN THE PROCESS
OF HOW WE WORK TOGETHER.
YOU TRUST THE FOLKS THAT YOU'VE
HIRED TO TALK TO US DIRECTLY. TO
COMMUNICATE.
VERY CLEARLY AND VERY
TRANSPARENTLY SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
HERE TODAY AND THAT YOU TRUST
YOUR TEAM THAT WORKS WITH US.
ON YOUR SIDE TO BE ABLE TO
CONVEY TO YOU THE SENTIMENTS OF
THE LEGISLATURE.
AS WELL AS THE DIRECTION THAT
YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE THE NEW
DIRECTION FOR PGA ANY AS WAS
DESCRIBED HERE TODAY THE NEW
VISION.
THAT YOU HAVE AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE ARE PROTECTING
REPAIRS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD.
IN A VISION THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE WHILE I KNOW THAT THAT
PATHWAY WILL BE CHALLENGING.
WON'T BE EASY -- WE MAY OFTEN
DISAGREE.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THAT
WE BUILD THE TRUST THAT WE NEED
TO BUILD BOTH WITHIN YOUR
COMPANY WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE
AND FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT I'M
HOPING I AM.
AVAILABLE AS YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SEE ME I WILL MAKE THAT A
PRIORITY -- SO FAR THE PEOPLE IT.
REPRESENTED HERE I THINK OF THAT
A GOOD JOB OF EXPLAINING TO ME.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING TO THEM?
AND IT'S BEEN VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT YOU SAID TO ME TODAY.
AND I WOULD EXPECT THAT I WOULD
HAVE.
THE UNVARNISHED TRUTH SPOKEN TO
BE BY THE PEOPLE I WORK WITH SO.
AND IF I HEAR OTHERWISE WE'LL
HAVE NEW PEOPLE WORKING THERE.
THERE YOU GO.
WELL LET ME JUST LET ME JUST SAY
THAT I APPRECIATE YOUR CANDOR
AND YOUR YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS
BEHIND THE YOUR RESPONSES.
AS I MENTIONED AT THE ONSET OF
THIS -- HEARING IT IS -- IT IS A
HEARING WHAT IT IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND WE HAD
INDICATED THAT WE WOULD MAKE
SOMETIME AVAILABLE FOR THE
PUBLIC.
TO TO ADDRESS THIS -- MINUTE.
TAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY NOW THERE
ARE OTHER QUESTIONS THAT I THINK
THAT.
ALL OF US CAN PROBABLY ENGAGE
WITH YOU ON THAT AS TIME GOES ON
WE'LL DO SO BUT WE DO APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU'VE FIELDED --
THE QUESTIONS TODAY -- THAT
DEALT WITH A VARIETY OF ISSUES
THAT.
ARE VERY MUCH ON THE FOREFRONT
OF THE CONVERSATION AROUND P.
JEANNIE BUT JUST NOT.
PGA ANY BUT ALSO HOW WE GO
FORWARD TO STABILIZE THIS VERY
IMPORTANT INDUSTRY AND AND
CALIFORNIA -- AND BEFORE I TAKE.
PUBLIC COMMENT I THINK THAT WE
ARE ALL PROBABLY HEARING AND
BECOMING MORE AWARE OF THAT --
THE CAMPFIRE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
OF THE INITIATION OF THE FIRE
DOES SEEM BASED ON OUR CAL FIRES
ASSESSMENT -- TO FALL WITH P.
JEANNIE -- MY FEELING IS THAT
THE THAT THE THE P. GINNY AS
SORT OF AN TO SUBPOENA THIS --
AND SO DOES REALLY CHANGE TOO
MUCH OF THE THE DYNAMIC SO THEN
NOW IT'S REAL WOOD AND THEY'RE
LOOKING TO IMPLEMENT -- NEXT
STEPS.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO TAKE
A SECOND.
TO RESPOND YOU DON'T HAVE -- TO
BUT IF YOU'RE SO INCLINED.
TO MAKE A STATEMENT AS IT
RELATES TO THIS ARE CAL FIRE
DETERMINATION.
ARE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY SO.
SO I HAVE MADE THE ASSUMPTION
WHEN I GOT HERE THAT.
P. GINNY EQUIPMENT BECAUSE THE
FIRE JUST MADE THE ASSUMPTION
BECAUSE THAT'S THE BEST PLACE TO
START.
THE COMPANY HAD SAID IN ITS
FILINGS RECENTLY IT WAS PROBABLE.
THAT THEIR EQUIPMENT CAUSED THE
FIRE SO.
THIS IS A IT'S NOT A
DISAPPOINTMENT.
THAT.
IS A DIFFERENT DISAPPOINTED THAT
THIS HAPPENED -- LET'S NOT DO IT
AGAIN.
WE WILL NOW TAKE.
PROBABLY IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION
THE ONE OPPOSE IT OR JUST A
COMMENT WILL GIVE YOU -- TWO
MINUTES IF THERE'S ANYONE FROM
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE AT THIS
TIME.
ON THAT NOTE OKAY.
IT'S STILL TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU -- MICHAEL LOOK AT OR
ON BEHALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION I
APPRECIATE LIKE ALL OF YOU THE
FACT THAT P. GINNY CEO.
WAS HERE I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS SINCE
FIRST TIME I CAN REMEMBER THAT
FRANKLY SO.
THAT'S A GOOD THING AND WE'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT CARING AND
TRUST AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE
KNOW ABOUT TRUST AS IT TAKES
YEARS TO BUILD.
SECONDS TO BREAK AND FOREVER TO
REPAIR.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
FOREVER.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME P. GINNY HAS
BROKEN THE TRUST IT'S NOT THE
SECOND TIME.
IT'S NOT THE THIRD TIME IT'S NOT
EVEN THE FOURTH TIME.
AND MY CONCERN IS IT WON'T BE
THE LAST TIME. ONE OF THE THINGS
I HEARD IT WAS VERY DISCOURAGING
TODAY WAS THAT P. GENIES FAILURE
IN SAN BRUNO WAS FROM A LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT I THINK
THEY KNEW THEIR SYSTEM WAS
PROBLEMATIC.
I THINK IT WAS A LACK OF
PRIORITY TO SPEND THE MONEY TO
FIX THAT SYSTEM AND THAT'S THE
INHERENT PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
SEEING WITH PJ NAY.
ITS PROFITS OVER SAFETY.
JUDGE ALSO I THINK HAS.
HONED IN ON THIS IS PART THE
PROBATION DISCUSSION.
HE'S TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY'VE
PROVIDED FOUR POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN DIVIDENDS OF THE LAST
THREE YEARS THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY.
THEY COULD HAVE GONE INTO SAFETY
THEY DIDN'T WANT AND A
SHAREHOLDER PROFITS.
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT
I'M A FREE MARKET GUY REPRESENT
A LOT OF FREE MARKET COMPANIES.
BUT THERE'S GOT TO BE A BALANCE
THERE AND THAT BALANCE IS
LACKING IN P. JEANNIE.
WERE ALREADY SEEING IT EVEN
MOVING FORWARD AND THIS GETS TO
THE QUESTIONS I THINK THAT MISS
RAMOS WAS WAS POSING AT THE AND
WE APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
AND THAT ISSUE SHAREHOLDERS NEED
TO OWN UP TO THEIR MISTAKES.
WE HEARD TODAY THAT P. GENIES.
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CAMPFIRE
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR IN THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS OR MONTHS WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WERE CRIMINALLY
NEGLIGENT AND ALL INDICATIONS
ARE THAT THEY COULD VERY WELL BE.
CRIMINALLY NEGLIGENT BECAUSE
THEY KNEW THAT TRANSMISSION LINE
WAS PROBLEMATIC.
IN THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON
THOSE TRANSMISSION LINES FOR NOT
ONE YEAR NOT TWO YEARS BUT MAY
BE AS MANY AS FOUR OR FIVE YEARS.
THAT'S ON THEM.
THAT CAN'T COME BACK TO RATE
PAYERS AND THAT'S THE FEAR THAT
WE A LOT OF US HAD WITH NINE A
ONE LAST YEAR.
THAT HAS TO BE ON SHAREHOLDERS.
KEEP YOUR EYE ON THE BALL THE
BALL IN BANKRUPTCY RIGHT NOW P.
G.'S PREOCCUPIED WITH RE ISSUING
THEIR DIVIDENDS.
THEY WANT TO START RE ISSUING
PROFITS TO SHAREHOLDERS THE
CENTERS A. EMERGE FROM
BANKRUPTCY THERE'S GOING TO BE A
PUSH TO RE ISSUE THAT DIVIDEND.
THOSE DIVIDEND SHOULD GO TO PAY
FOR ANY RESPONSIBILITY THEY HAVE
FROM ALL OF THESE FIRES.
BEFORE RATE PAYERS ARE ASKED TO
PAY NOT AFTER.
SO WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THAT AND
NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE HEARINGS
THAT COME AFTER THIS TODAY FROM
THE RATE PAYER CRYPSIS FOCUS ON
THAT DIVIDEND.
BECAUSE THAT'S MONEY IF YOU CAN
GO TO SHAREHOLDERS.
IT CAN GO TO PAY BACK THE DAMAGE
THEY'VE DONE OVER TIME AND THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEE NO OTHERS WHO WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT OR ADDRESS THE OTHER
COMMITTEE LET ME JUST THANK THE
MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE AND ARE
EX OFFICIO MEMBERS -- FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTION -- TO THIS DIALOGUE
AND MISTER JOHNSON AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOU -- COMING HERE
TODAY AND GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GET TO TO KNOW YOU AND SOME
OF YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP STYLE
AND AS YOU SAY.
ALL OF THIS IS GOING TO BE WORK
IN PROGRESS AND AS YOU MENTIONED
IN YOUR EARLIER STATEMENTS THAT.
TRUST IS EARNED AND YOU ARE
CERTAINLY -- LAYING IT OUT HERE
THAT YOU'RE PREPARED TO DO THE
WORK NECESSARY TO BUILD THE
TRUST -- THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
ISSUES OUT HERE THAT ARE TO BE
RESOLVED -- AND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
WE WANT TO BE IN A POSITION TO
BE ABLE TO COLLABORATE -- WE
TAKE THAT AS WE SAID BEFORE THAT.
OF THIS INDUSTRY IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THERE'S A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
FOR UTILITIES.
UP WITH THEIR SAFETY IS PRIMARY
AS WE'VE SEEN AND HEARD FROM SO
MANY.
OF OUR MEMBERS TODAY -- WE CARRY
A LOT OF WEIGHT.
AROUND THESE DECISIONS BECAUSE
REPAIRS ARE ALWAYS THE ONES THAT
SEEM TO FIND THEMSELVES IN A
POSITION OF HAVING ABSORBED --
BAD CONDUCT -- EVEN NEGLIGENT
CONDUCT.
AND AS SUCH THERE HAS TO BE A
LITTLE BIT OF A SEIZURE SHIFT IN
SOME OF THIS -- BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO BUILDING A
RELATIONSHIP WITH HERE.
AND WE THANK YOU AND GOOD GOD
SPEED.
GOD SPEED -- LET ME JUST ADD A
CLOSING.
LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT ON
TUESDAY MAY TWENTY FOURTH FIRST
WE WILL BE HOLDING AN ADDITIONAL
HEARING ON SAFETY AND IT WILL BE
LOOKING AT THE UTILITIES WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS.
WE EXPECT THE RELEASE OF THE
DRAFT NINE OH ONE COMMISSION
REPORT LATER THIS MONTH.
AND WILL ALSO SCHEDULE AN
ADDITIONAL INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON THAT REPORT.
WITH THAT.
WERE INJURED